today I'm gonna be talking about some
work I recently did with my supervisors
Giovanni and Chris and with two
collaborators of ours Romi and Rob and
their neuro scientists so this talk is
gonna have a bit of a neuroscience feel
to it before I start just a few words
about myself I'm a PhD student at
Imperial College finishing my PhD this
summer most of my research is involved
with computational statistics driven by
problems in sort of computational
neuroscience so in particular I work
with functional MRI which measures blood
flow in different parts of the brain and
I try to Decorah late that and
understand the networks that sort of
drive different tasks and well I use
Python which is why I'm here so in this
talk I'm going to talk about restricted
and deep Boltzmann machines I want to
try to give you guys an idea of what
they are what are the advantages and
disadvantages of using these models and
I want to briefly discuss training and
model selection and I'm gonna try to
motivate all this with an application to
text mining and so so just to give some
context and some motivation for this
work
there's tons of reasons why you might
want to build a text mining model things
like information retrieval information
extraction but actually in the context
of this work we had a very specific
motivation so we recently did some work
which we sort of quite provocatively
called the automatic neuroscientist and
the idea behind this work was to somehow
try to redefine the way a functional MRI
experiment works so the way it currently
works is a neuroscientist will choose an
experimental task say you're gonna watch
a video they'll put us put a subject in
the scanner and then they'll observe the
brain activation from that from that
task but actually what the
neuroscientist is interested in is a
specific brain region right so they'll
have in mind brain region X that they
want to activate and they'll have then
gone into the literature and said what
are the tasks one of the different tasks
which activate this brain region and
they'll have chosen the task as a
function of that so actually in the
traditional setting the mapping goes
from experiments to brain activation but
what the neuroscientist is really
interested in is going the other way
around right they want to choose a brain
activation and they want to optimally
learn the task which maximizes our brain
activation so just to put this in
context if you think of a commercial
example if you have
website say you want to maximize some
KPI for example conversion rate you
might play around with the different
parameters of your website but
ultimately what you're interested in you
want to maximize that conversion rate
right so you want to automatically learn
the parameters of your your website
which lead to maximum conversion and
actually the framework that we used here
is a was developed recently in a machine
learning context and in order to tune
hyper parameters for models so if you
think of like deep learning models they
have a lot of hyper parameters and often
tuning these high parameters is really
difficult but measuring the model
performance is quite easy so the
framework that we used here effectively
measures the performance and
automatically Tunes these hyper
parameters so that's a bit of the
motivation behind this and so we had
this sort of setup where you had a
subject in the scanner you measured the
brain activity for a given experiment
you compare that to the target brain
region and then you use that to sort of
redefine the experimental paradigm that
you showed the subject and he sort of
iterated this in real-time and so we did
this for a very simple experiment which
is contained sort of audio-visual and
cues and we found it to work and that we
were quite excited by that and so we
thought great it sort of works for an
audio-visual task what if we could be
more ambitious and when instead of just
searching one audio-visual task we could
search 20 tasks well what if what if we
could be really ambitious and we could
search through all the tasks ever
proposed in the sort of neuroscientific
literature automatically in real time
and sort of this is what led us to sort
of collecting a bunch of near scientific
papers and building a new scientific
corpus and then trying to sort of study
that and sort of embedding that in some
high dimensional space which would make
it easy to search over so fortunately
for us we're not the first people to
think about this
there was a Nature Methods paper in 2011
which did something similar what they
effectively did was they scraped a bunch
of neuro scientific papers so they went
across and collected the text for ten
thousand year scientific papers and
along with the text they also collected
the brain regions that were reported to
be activated in the corresponding papers
right so they have this rich data set
where on the one hand you have the text
the vocabulary which describes the
experiment that was done in some
scientific study and then you have in
some standardized space the brain
regions that were reported to be
activated by that study and if you want
to play around with this is the status
that's freely available at nearest an
org
so in this and in this work we didn't
actually use the full text we'll just
use the the abstracts for the for the
various papers and there's two reasons
for this first of all the abstract
length is much less variable it's much
more from a genius across papers and
that sort of made learning a little bit
easier and it also sort of reduced the
size of the vocabulary cuz it was pure
words and second of all we sort of
hypothesized that the M the abstract
would contain most of the information
about the about the task that was
performed right so it will be like a
concise description of what the paper
was about so here is an example entry of
what we what we were working with so
here you have an abstract for sort of a
human episodic memory task which is
which is a sort of a verbal associative
encoding tasks so this is what we would
be feeding in to our algorithm to try
and learn a distribution of it over the
text so given sort of ten thousand
abstracts of this form we have sort of
two overarching objectives right the
first of all is to try and sort of
cluster all these documents together so
that you could put papers that sort of
describe similar experiments in similar
clusters so that you could search over
them efficiently and inherent in any
clustering task is some measure of
similarity as a measure of distance and
actually defining robust measures of
similarity or distance across text is
quite tricky but it's far easier to do
this across vector spaces right and
there's a whole wealth of knowledge on
how to define measure of similarity
across vector spaces so the the main
objective of this work was to somehow
learn a low dimensional vector
representation of each document which
captured the semantic regularity of each
of the text right so what we effectively
wanted to do was to take each abstract
for each paper and sort of embed this in
some high dimensional vector space which
captured the the semantic regularities
and what the tasks that this abstract
was describing and then once you have
everything in a high dimensional vector
space you can sort of leverage the vast
field of work in ml and all this also to
algorithms which are what well-suited to
dealing with continuous spaces so that's
those are the sort of two main
objectives of this work and we did this
using Bolton machines so I know it's a
Sunday afternoon and you know before I
get sort of get stuck into discussing
details of the model I wanted to give
you guys a taster for what we were able
to achieve so on the left-hand side here
what we have each dot corresponds to a a
document in our corpus and what we've
done here is effectively each document
is going up through the deep Boltzmann
machine and it's been embedded in some
high dimensional vector space and in
this case the vector space was 50
dimensional we've then reduced the
dimensionality of this to two dimensions
using t-sne which is a stochastic
neighbor embedding algorithm basically
what it tries to do is it tries to find
a two dimensional embedding of that of
the high dimensional space where the
distances between the points are sort of
them preserved we then ran some really
simple clustering so in this case was
k-means clustering and try and learn
some clusters over this embedding and
what you see on the on the right is them
the associated brain activations
associated with some of these clusters
that we learned now if the clusters were
totally meaningless the brain activation
maps that you would see on the on your
left and will be sort of homogeneous
across the whole brain but actually it
turns out that some of the clusters
we've learned are able to specialize on
very specific brain regions so for
example this cluster here clearly picks
up the more the motor brain region so
going back to our sort of experimental
design context if the neuroscientist
said I want to really activate the motor
brain region we might say great we've
had we have these these papers
corresponding to cluster number six here
you might want to study the abstracts
there and and search those and search
those tasks described there and because
they're going to lead to high activation
in the brain region similarly we have
the amygdala which is highlighted here
by cluster number three and then and
then exactly the same way if the
neuroscientists to say I really want to
target the amygdala we would say great
you know look at the look at the
documents in these clusters so in the
remainder of this talk I'll sort of
describe how we got to this plot so I
want to start by talking about
restricted Boltzmann machines which are
sort of a special case of deep Bolton
machines and before I sort of describe
them I just want to sort of highlight
what the advantages of that of both
machines are and how they're slightly
different from traditional neural
networks so both machines as opposed to
traditional neural networks are
generative models so they're actually
looking to learn a distribution over
your data
and this is slightly more difficult
right because you need to you need to
model all your data points well one of
the advantages of learning a generative
model is that once you've learned this
distribution of your data you can then
sample from it and you can effectively
dream up new new new data points and you
can you can generate more data the
reason people like Baltimore change is
because they're fully unsupervised so
this makes them suitable for sort of pre
training neural networks so if you
imagine a context where you have a small
set of labeled data but you have a large
set of unlabeled data then you can
leverage this unlabeled data learn the
distribution of over this unlabeled data
using a Boltzmann machine and then use
the weights that you've learned as a as
I sort of warm start for your neural
network and then find to you fine-tune
those using back propagation
however there's two sort of key
disadvantages to ball teams the first is
that training is not straightforward so
since we're dealing with sort of
graphical models and the training is it
isn't just the case of back propagating
through the algorithm and it's a little
bit more complicated and secondly model
selection and model comparison so if you
remember we're in a totally unsupervised
setting so model selection and needs to
be based on some sort of validate
out-of-sample likelihood and actually
this is really complicated in both
machines because there's a normalizing
constant which is a bit of a headache to
learn so those would be I would say the
two main disadvantages so to give you
guys an idea of a bult machine of what a
restricted Boltzmann is it's a special
case of a general Boltzmann so if you
assume we have some sort of vector of
visible units here for now let's just
assume they're binary so just treat
these as if there were pixels in some
sort of a black and white image and you
wanted to learn a distribution over
these over these binary random variables
in a both machine you hypothesize that
this distribution is driven by or
related to some latent hidden units so
in addition to your visible units you
also have some hidden units which sort
of determine this distribution and in
the Boltzmann you assume that the
distribution is sort of specified by
pairwise potentials across these units
so each of these edges effectively
determines a sort of piecewise or sort
of statistical dependency across the
visible and the
and in a ball team oisin effectively
each visible unit has a conditional
dependency on every single other unit in
your in your in your in your model and
what this means is these these models
are really expressive and really
flexible and they're able to learn sort
of really complicated distributions but
they're also really difficult to train
because you have all these dependencies
to account for and so the idea in a
restricted Boltzmann machine is that you
restrict the graphical structure of your
model in particular you sort of ensure
and force the destructor to be bipartite
so you force all these edges between
visible units to be 0 to be removed for
the model and all these that just
between hidden units to be removed and
so effectively you only have edges from
visible to hidden units and vice-versa
and as we'll see this is going to really
simplify training and inference on these
models so restricted Boltzmann machines
are sort of models that came out from
the statistical physics literature and
they're what's called energy based
models so each of these pairwise
potentials is parametrized by some real
number and effectively what this what
you can think of this number here as
being if this number is positive and
this visible unit is on it's gonna
really encourage this hidden unit to be
on and vice versa right so these models
are entirely undirected so if this if
this number is positive and this hidden
unit is on this guy's gonna be
encouraged to be on and so learning our
six bolts of machine effectively boils
down to learning these set of parameters
and what you effectively want to do is
sort of maximize some energy function
and so in the context of training we
only have the visible units so what you
want to maximize is the likelihood of
the visible units after you've
marginalized out these hidden units
right so you sort of sum over all the
possible hidden units and you want to
maximize the likelihood of your visible
units now because of the bipartite
structure you can actually calculate
that likelihood analytically or up to a
normalizing constant and and that's what
makes sort of training feasible so as I
mentioned this bipartite structure leads
to a few sort of desirable properties
the first of them is that the visible
units or the hidden units are
conditionally independent given the
other units right so what I mean by this
is given a set of hidden units each of
your visible units is conditionally in
and so if you wanted to sample your
visible units given the hidden units
all you'd have to do is sample each of
these guys independently so instead of
having to sample a vector here you just
have to sample a bunch of univariate
random variables and so that makes life
a lot easier and it's the same is true
vice-versa furthermore each of the
distributions of the head of the visible
units we know analytically so we know
that each of the visible units given
given your hidden units will be a
Bernoulli random variable with some with
a parameter specified by the sum of the
inputs pass through some Sigma little
function so actually sampling the
visible given the hidden units or vice
versa is really easy and we can do it in
close form and actually training
restricted Boltzmann machines and deep
balls machines just boils down to doing
this a bunch of times in a special way
so just to make this perfectly clear if
you wanted to do this in Python and you
have some vector of hidden units all you
have to do is take the dot product with
your weight matrix and then pass that
through some sigmoid function and all
you do is then some sample by no
Bernoulli random variable with that
activation function so in Python you can
sort of sample the visible given the
hidden units or vice versa in just two
lines of code so training so like in
traditional neural networks training
precedes by a sort of maximum likely
hidden stochastic gradient descent but
as I said the problem is this derivative
is no longer available in closed form
like it is in back propagation and the
reason for that is we're trying to learn
a graphical model where the hidden units
are actually random variables and so
this derivative actually boils down to
the sum of two expectations the first is
a sort of data dependent expectation and
it's the expectation under the
distribution of the hidden units given
the visible units now because of in a
restrictive Boltzmann we know this
distribution in closed form so actually
getting this expectation and getting an
unbiased estimate of this expectation is
really easy and we can do that
analytically the second expectation
which is the data independent
expectation is a little bit trickier
because this is an expectation over the
Joint Distribution over the visible and
hidden units and we don't know what this
is so this is this is well sort of the
headache comes in and this is where we
need to approximate the derivative so
this guy can be done analytically and
we have an unbiased estimate but this
guy must be approximated using sort of
Markov chain Monte Carlo methods so just
just to reiterate the data dependent
expectation we can calculate really
easily the data independent expectation
we need to sort of approximate using a
Markov chain Monte Carlo so the approach
that typically that is typically used is
sort of to exploit this conditional
independence structure and you should
just sample the visible given the hidden
units and the hidden given the visible
units and you iterate this K times and
as K goes to infinity you approximate
the Joint Distribution exactly but of
course no one has time to let K go to
infinity so actually in practice you
just you just often set K equals some
number
often K equals one is used and
empirically it's been shown to perform
fairly well but actually people that
know about MCMC will tell you this is a
very bad approximation to that
expectation so just to sort of show you
how you would do this in Python the data
dependent expectation can be calculated
in closed form really easily so all you
do is you sort of take some visible
units which is your data you feed that
up you sample your hidden units and this
is your sort of data dependent
expectation then to learn your data
independent expectation you just sort of
iterate in this Gibbs sampling procedure
and so here I've just done it once but
if you were to do this sort of within a
for loop k times you would effectively
get a better approximation and then you
just take the difference of these two
terms and that's your that's the
direction of your grading and you just
take a small step in that direction and
you iterate so restricted Bolton
machines are unsupervised learning
methods so it's especially important to
sort of try and avoid overfitting that's
a it's also the case that they're
unsupervised so you have to be extra
careful to avoid overfitting so in the
previous talk we had some slides showing
the likely hidden in the test error and
the validation error and that's
certainly one way you can sort of avoid
overfitting once these two start to
diverge significantly you should
probably stop training because your
overfitting but the methods the that I
used in this works is trying to avoid
overfitting was just drop out and what
this effectively boils down to is you
just sort of at training time randomly
select hidden units to remove from your
model and what this effectively does is
it encourages the hidden units to be
robust and not sort of
depend on the activations of other
hidden units another way of thinking of
dropout is that you're learning an
ensemble of neural networks so since
you're randomly dropping out different
guys you're sort of learning different
neural networks with different number of
hidden units at each M at each iteration
and then at prediction time or learning
time you sort of put them all together
so it's a bit of an ensemble of neural
networks so so far I've been describing
bolting machines for binary random
variables but of course this work is
about text so we need to sort of extend
that to text so a really naive way to
model text is to is to treat it as a
binary random variables right so if we
think for example the sentence the
ability to bind information so on you
can model this as binary random
variables by using an incidence matrix
so for example this this vector here
would be a 1 because ability is the
second entry of that of that sentence
and then all other entries in this in
this column would will be 0 and
similarly these two entries would be 1
because bind and information of the
third in the fourth entries for that
matrix the problem with modeling text in
this way is that it's incredibly
wasteful right each column only ever has
one nonzero entry and moreover each of
these guys is only really going to be
activated when say for example
information is the fifth word in your
text and that might not happen that
often
the other problem is that a number of
parameters explodes right so here you've
described some document as an incidence
matrix where the number of rows is equal
to the number of words in your
vocabulary and the number of columns is
equal to the number of sort of words in
that document and so you have tons and
tons of visible units and each one of
these visible units is connected to all
your hidden units right so the number of
parameters really explodes quite quickly
and so this is quite a wasteful way of
modeling text so in this work we sort of
took a more parsimonious approach and we
sort of just modeled the word counts so
as opposed to modeling word location you
sort of just forget about the order in
which the words occur and you just try
and model the word count and so each
visible unit is no longer a matrix but
it's just a vector and so the IJ the I
entry is the number of times that word
occurs in your document
so of course since we're now modeling
word counts as opposed to binary random
variables the distribution of our
visible units is no longer binary but
it's multinomial but actually all that
really changes is the conditional
distribution of the visible given the
hidden units which now will follow a
softmax distribution all the other
properties are training the versatile
vos machine sort of remain unchanged and
and actually more generally this is true
for sort of any exponential family
visible unit so you can sort of play
around with with different classes of
visible units so to move on to deep
Boltzmann machines so the idea and deep
Boltzmann machines is you continue to
propagate this bipartite structure
upwards right so in a restrictive
Boltzmann we just had one layer of
hidden units here we sort of have an
additional layer of hidden units on top
of that and what the idea behind this is
this first layer learns sort of a
initial approximation or distribution of
your data and the second layer then
learns an additional distribution over
your first layer and so you are able to
learn sort of high dimensional or really
complicated representations of your data
as before you have sort of an energy
function and each of these edges is
parametrized by a weight so all you're
basically trying to do is learn these
weights and these weights and again as
before we sort of perceived by a maximum
likelihood the problem is the derivative
of the likelihood is the sum is again
the sum of the data dependent and a data
independent expectation but now neither
of these guys is available in closed
form and both of them are quite
difficult so in the case of the data
dependent expectation you have to the
expectation is over the distribution of
both layers of hidden units given your
visible units and you normally have
access to this in closed form right and
so the approach that people typically
take is to use variational inference and
basically what this boils down to is you
say okay I'm just going to assume each
of these guys is independently Bernoulli
random variables and I'm just going to
try and learn the parameters of these
guys that closest approximate the the
true Joint Distribution or the true
conditional distribution and what this
basically boils down to is you say okay
the I unit in my in my first layer is
gonna be Bernoulli with some parameter
mu so some probability of being on and
the iith unit in mice
in my second layer is also gonna be
Berlin dude and you sort of iterate
these parameters and try and learn the
parameters to minimize some distance to
the true conditional distribution and
what it basically boils down to is you
just basically iterate these two these
two equations up until convergence then
in the case of the data independent
distribution we have to learn the Joint
Distribution over these three layers now
right and so again we sort of follow the
same philosophy and we sort of use
Markov chain Monte Carlo and but as as
opposed to sort of just sampling up and
down sort of one time the approach that
is typically advocated is to sort of
keep a keep a sort of a a bunch of
particles and whilst you're training and
in each iteration as opposed to starting
the Markov chain from scratch you sort
of iterate these em particles up and
down your hidden network the idea here
is that if the weights in your network
are sort of changing at a slower rate
then these particles are approximating
this joint distribution then you're able
to get your able to get your you're
gonna be able to get a good
approximation to the expectation of
interest so the objective function in
deep Boltzmann machines is highly non
convex and like all methods and deep
learning initializing the parameters is
actually really important and so the way
deep Boltzmann chains are typically
trained is you sort of pre train your
weights and then you fine-tune them
using the the method I just described so
in this worked we sort of preacher in
the deep Boltzmann machines by first of
all learning a restricted Boltzmann
machine over the visible units and then
sort of propagating the data through
that and sampling these guys and then
treating samples from the first layer as
visible units and learning an additional
restrictive Boltzmann on top of that and
then you do some some sort of minor
adjustments to the weights and those
weights can be used as a sort of
starting point for your network so that
was what we did now to just sort of
describe the results that we got so we
sort of trained a two-layer and deep
Boltzmann machine with 50 binary random
variables in each layer and then
pre-training was done with using
contrastive divergence that basically
means i took one step at each iteration
of estimating my data independent
distribution and I used drop out with
some
with a 1 in 10 chance of dropping up the
the hidden units and so just to remind
you what the data was it was abstracts
for about 10,000 scientific publications
the average length of the document was
about 80 words and they were cavalier
with a thousand words and so first of
all the first thing we can do is we can
sort of pass each word through the deep
Boltzmann machine and so represent each
word is some sort of high dimensional in
some high dimensional space and then
over the district over these sort of
vector representations of the words we
can just run some really basic
clustering so here we're just around
k-means and then i'm and i'm just
showing you here some clusters which
we've learned so for example the first
cluster we have sort of memory retrieval
the hippocampus which is a brain region
associated with recollection the second
cluster sort of corresponds to sort of
language we have a final cluster down
here which corresponds to sort of
pathologies and disorders and so you can
see that the representations that are
being learned over words make some sense
again and we can take this sort of
representation of words and try and sort
of map it down into a two dimensional
space which is what we have in so the
top left corner here and if you zoom in
to some of these some of these regions
you can see that they're sort of like
semantic meaning in there in the
representation right so for example in
this in this corner here we have the
amygdala and words like emotion and
empathy and so this sort of corresponds
to the emotional coordinates down here
you have like recollection and retrieval
and encoding and over there you sort of
have words to with like aging and
development the other thing you can do
to sort of make sure that you've learnt
to a reasonable distribution of your
data is you can take a word pass it up
through the network so into the second
hidden layer and then come back down and
see which which words are sort of highly
activated so in this case for example we
put the word memory in as input went up
up through the network and back down and
these are the words that sort of had
highest probability density right so I
should point out that working comes out
here because working memory is a really
big thing in your science and this was a
neuroscience corpus if you were to do
train this on a different corpus I would
not expect working
the associated with memory and you can
see that sort of the words that are
being returned sort of make some sense
right so yeah if you put in face you get
facial faces face if you put in disorder
you get patients and a bunch of
disorders
so it's alerts a sort of fairly
reasonable distribution over over the
data and finally another thing that's
sort of exciting is that these hidden
units appear to be somewhat
discriminative right so if you just
flick one of the hidden units on and
then work your way down the network you
can see which are the words which are
sort of associated with this hidden unit
so for example if you just click the
fourth hidden unit on you get words like
younger older aging those are the words
that are sort of most activated by this
unit if you sort of turn the
thirty-eight unit on you get words like
reading language so these the units
appear to be associated with sort of
specific tasks and finally we get to the
picture I showed you the beginning where
here we have all the all of the
documents that have been sort of put
into this high dimensional space and
then we sort of try and try to shrink
that back down to two dimensions and
then we've run some really simple
clustering on that so that's all I have
thank you very much any questions thanks
it was a great talk indeed pretty slides
when you were showing the yeah so all
these units are from the first layer
right so what I've done here is I've
flicked on a unit in the top layer and
then propagate it down so so I've sort
of I sort of flicked this unit on for
example and then I all the other units
are often and I can sort of sample these
guys can this one want just this guy
beyond and then sample those guys so
just wondering if you try it's switching
on on the units from the from the lower
layer and see if there is like this
difference that you would expect it oh
just something wanting symbol in them
I guess these models they're all
undirected right so all these edges are
undirected so I would expect similar
things to happen I haven't I haven't
actually tried you mean just just
switching on a word for example right
yeah so you mentioned that's you know
the first layer learns simple features
and then the next layer
sort of more complex things well that's
like the idea right I can't prove it
yeah yeah couple of slides ago you had I
put in some words and some words come
out can you go back to that one yeah
there was it was yeah so obviously I
don't really understand how this works
because I think these in order yes yes
yes so for example if you put in memory
and you work your way up and down the
network then they're just then you you
get a basically a distribution of your
words right which so the memory was the
most strongly associated word with
memory yes why it's why is face not the
most strongly associated with face yeah
yeah so it's not always the case that
the same word should be the most
associated with itself because I'm the
most strongly associated person with
myself yeah yeah you're right
I guess I don't really have a good
answer for you for that and ultimately
the way this training has been done is
it's been based on a sort of a noisy
gradient and so I guess if these words
sort of occur together sufficiently many
times and you're only approximating
you're only getting like a noisy
approximation then it could be that this
is just noise yeah I mean I guess this
is just sort of reassure you that you're
learning a reasonable distribution of
your words and I would only really
expect the words to sort of them be
roughly in this area I I don't think I
wouldn't expect it to be the number one
word and the other reason for that is
because for each word
I didn't sure in size but you also learn
a bias vector so words that occur really
really frequently will have a high bias
vector because they're more likely to be
switched on and so for example words
that don't occur that frequently will
have a sort of poopy sort of switched
off because they're not likely to occur
so every time I guess it here with mode
and the default mode network is a
sentence that occurs really frequently
so this sort of makes sense to me but
also the words network and default
probably occur much more frequently than
mode and maybe that's why that's
happening there that would be sort of my
initial guess
yeah sorry the face faces and facial are
all the same word essentially where
social doesn't have many synonyms so
that's probably why the waiting's been
split amongst three Robin right yeah
okay if there are no more questions
please thank Ricardo